شاعره وباحثه اكاديميه واسم بارز في
الاعلام الخليجي والعربي مشوار بدا منذ
عام
1988 ظهرت ملامح الموهبه مبكرا جدا كانت
مؤديه صوتيه ومذيعه في فضائيه البحرين
كانت اصغر قارئه نشرات اخبار رئيسيه
واصبحت مقدمه برامج حتى قبل ان تتخرج من
الجامعه هي علم من اعلام الاعداد والحوار
وتقديم البرامج التلفزيونيه العربيه التقت
في تلك الرحله بالعديد بالعمالقه الادب
والفن والثقافه في الوطن العربي هي عضو
بجمعيه اللغه العربيه رئيسه اللجنه
الثقافيه لنادي خريجي جامعه البحرين
واخيرا حاصله على درجه الدكتوراه في الادب
الحقيقي والنقد الادبي لها عدد من الاعمده
الصحفيه الاسبوعيه والمؤلفات بالاضافه الى
دواوين الشعر
هذه اللغه التي تحمل ثقافه عظيمه وارث
عظيما لغه القران الكريم بث في هذه اللغه
عنصر حياه عنصر ديمومه عنصر وجود
لا احب العربيه
هل تعتبرين ان لغتنا العربيه في خطر اليوم
ام ان لغه القران الكريم لا يمكن لها ان
تموت سؤال جدا حلو انا تكلمت في هذا
العمود عندي عامود اسبوعي بجريده الامارات
اليوم نلتقي اا العربيه العربيه
اللغه التي نتكلم بها للاسف نكتب بها يعني
هذه الجيل الان يكتب الحروف همم يعني
الحروف الانجليزيه
ويكتبها بطريقه عربيه يعني يلفظها
بالطريقه العربيه همم يعني
همم اللغه العربيه احنا ما راح نقول ان هي
في خطر
سؤال حقيقه يعني انا ما اريد الفلسفه على
المشاهدين صباحا هل هو قلق اللغه ام قلق
اصحاب اللغه يعني لانه اصحاب اللغه احنا
نح اللغه عندها ارث وعندها ثقافه وعندها
ولغه النص المقدس عندنا القران الكريم لكن
حقيقه خلينا نكون شفافين وواضحين اللغه في
خطر يعني يوما ما المفكر والمنظر للحداثه
العربيه اجوا النسخه هذه اللغه ستنقرض
وقاموا عليه يعني قامت القيامه يعني
ادونيس لان هو يرى بعين المفكر هذه اللغه
احنا ما نستخدمها انا كثير من الاحيان
يعني اكون في اماكن عامه في مطعم او مقهى
اشوف يعني بنات من الجيل الجديد وعرب زين
قاعدين يتكلمون طول الوقت بالانجليزيه
ومره صادم فضول اقتربت من وحده وقلت لها
طيب ليش تتكلمين بالانجليزي ليش طول الوقت
يعني
قالت لي احنا نتكلم لان احنا نشانا ودرسنا
وكده طيب قلت لها طيب هذه اللغه اذا انتم
مارستوها راح تنقرض راح تنتهي يعني فعلا
قالت لي جمله كثير لفتت نظري قالت لا ما
راح تنتهي
لان هذه لغه القران الكريم طيب سؤالي
القران الكريم في البيت يعلوه الغبار لا
يمس ولا يقرا همم كيف ممكن هذا النص يفعل
هذا الذكر لحافظون انا نزلنا الذكر وان له
لحافظون طيب كيف احنا نحفظ القران هل يكفي
ان اتشدق واقول ان هذا لغه القران الكريم
وانا لا اقرا القران وانا لا اجود القران
وانا لا ارتل وانا لا امارس هذه اللغه
يعني كيف ممكن يضمن عنصر الحيويه والوجود
لهذه اللغه لان هذه اللغه تمارس هذه اللغه
كان اجتماعي اللغه كاني اجتماعيه يعني
يحيى وينمو على السنه المتحدثين اذا لم
نتكلم ولا نمارس اللغه ستموت هذه اللغه
احب اللغه اقتربوا منها صادقوها اجعلوها
تغمركم اجعلوها لغه حياه لغه يوميات لغه
محادثه لغه قراءه لغه التعامل
[موسيقى]